giờ trước quân sự tại kia ngày 1.2 cho biết,
lực lượng ngà đang ra tăng sự áp quan thành phố Phu Cô Cô,
ở miền đông của quay nà,
khiến ra trải những ngày qua dịch biến ál liệt,
của thế bộ tổng thầm của quay nà cho biết,
cơ định bị những này vẫn kiểm soát phần việc bắt Phu Cô Cô,
và tích tục phòng thu, thành phố Minoran lên gần,
khiến ngà thì đáu đệ mạnh tấn công, bằng bộ binh,
bằng dẫn đường và khai thác ưu thế quân số,
trong được kiện phòng phòng Phu Cô Cô, nhớ hạn chế.
Bộ Cô Cô là đồng mối đường xác quan trọng của tình đồ nhét,
với rất sổ chức trên sự khoảng sống như người
việc kiểm soát thành phố này sẽ mở đường trong áp,
tình xấu hơn và cạo đả chim toàn bộ tình đồ nhét.
Nếu Bộ Cô Thế thu, đời sự là tháng lợi nất của mắt cơ vạc,
kể thực ký trên đưa, ở đi ít ca đổ năm 2020,
nhóm phần tích trên sự độc lập liệt sát nổi,
bộ binh a đã thâm nhập một phần kia bắt Bộ Cô Cô,
và nhận định rao trang Trung quan của Cô Cô,
ở đây, đằng ở giải đoạn quyết định của Cô Cô,
sauong vừa chiến sự người kinh tuyến, trên bàn ngoại giao,
ngà tích tục yêu cầu của người nàn những phần lãnh thổ đồ nhét
còn lại trong các cuộc đảng phần họ bình giò Mỹ là mỹ lạm Trung Gián,
kia thì kinh quyết mắt Bộ,
hàng đích bấn đề lãnh thổ là không thể thương lợi.